speaking of victories for the left now
they say that silence speaks louder than
words well i think that's the case here
the met the medal winners gold silver
bronze for women's weightlifting did a
press conference a couple days ago
and um i want you to watch this entire
thing because they were pretty talkative
you know they were at a press conference
and they're asked questions and
they had plenty to say until the
questions turned to a certain subject
and then they all kind of
clammed up let's watch this this is for
emily
you went to the united states earlier
this year and you trained side by side
with sarah in utah
what was that experience like uh then
and now when you are competing on the
same olympic stage
um yeah it was fantastic um i was really
honored to be invited out to the states
to train with the guys and
especially siri you know we get on
really well and we're very like-minded
people
um and it was just really you know
inspiring to push each other and
to get each other ready for these
olympics and you know i'm absolutely
thrilled that i managed to share a
podium with her because she's
she's a real sweetheart there was a
historic night here uh
with laurel hubbard competing as the
first openly transgender in a uh
in a uh individual event and i was
wondering you know what you felt about
that and what you felt that took place
in in your sport
no thank you
no thank you don't want to talk about it
nothing to say
of course if they thought it was great
if they thought it was just great to
have
a man uh competing against them in a in
in in a women's in the women's sports
then they would they would say so
because that's what the media wants to
hear
so if they loved it then they would say
it's great yeah we should have more men
fantastic i love it i know
i love to see the destruction of my
sport i think it's the greatest thing
ever
that's how they felt they would have
said it
um so it's it's pretty clear no surprise
that they're not in favor
i i think we can
pretty reasonably assume that
almost every female athlete in the
country at every level feels this way
whether they say it out loud or not
but most of them are not going to say it
out loud and you know and i can unders
i can understand the silence i can i
understand what
motivates that because
they don't want to get involved in this
issue they don't want to talk about this
they just won the medals right they they
don't want the story to be about this
and that's what it would
turn into then there's going to be the
immense blowback and everything else and
there's going to be consequences to
their career and and so on and so forth
any any sponsorship
i don't know what kind of sponsorships a
female weightlifter could potentially
get but i'm sure there are some
and those are going to go away if they
start speaking out against this
um so i i get that i really do
but at the same time it's like we talked
about at the top
you know people want solutions but they
want the easy ones they don't want to
make serious sacrifices
and so most of the time when you hear
someone say what's the solution i
i only want to hear solutions the word
they're leaving out is easy
what's the easy solution
when most when in most cases there is
not an easy solution
especially when we're talking about our
culture
fixing problems that are deeply embedded
in the culture there's not an easy
solution
and that's the case here too
that at a certain point
people need to have some courage i
understand why people don't have courage
i understand again the instinct to not
want to get involved
and i'm very sympathetic to that i mean
these female athletes they didn't sign
up
for this you know
they don't want to get tossed into the
middle of this
drama over this guy who came i get that
it's like anybody else people working
their
normal jobs encounter a lot of
this kind of thing and they're supposed
to just put up with it they don't want
to speak up because they could lose
their job and you got to
you know you need your job you got to
provide for your family all these things
so i get all of that but but um at a
certain point
some courage is required
and if we're not gonna have any courage
at all if we're not willing to make any
sacrifices at all
then there is no hope
okay you may as well i mean flee into
the woods flee into the wilderness go
live in a desert in a cave or something
get out while you can go find a go find
a deserted island somewhere
i don't know maybe go down to antarctica
go somewhere because there is
no hope in this culture at all it is
nothing but darkness and despair
that lays before us if we have ruled out
simple courage
and that means just normal people who
don't want to get involved in these
kinds of things are going to have to get
involved and get involved just means
speak up
say i've had enough of this think about
that woman at
the the we spa in los angeles just a
normal woman
okay i'm sure she doesn't wake up every
day saying i want to get involved in
trans issues today
but she was in the in the locker room
and she saw a naked man
walk in there you know displaying his
penis to all the women and children
and she said no absolutely not and she
just reacted
with some courage
that's what women need to do in locker
rooms when the men come in and when they
intrude in sports
that's what men need to do also
you know what about all the men what
about what you know there was a woman
speaking out at
at wee spa what about all the
there weren't any other you know the
husbands were not in the locker room
when that guy walked in
but many of the women in that locker
room have husbands
and i'm sure those women came home and
told their husbands what happened
why aren't the husbands beating down the
door
and saying what are you doing subjecting
my wife and my children to this
so some basic courage is needed to begin
with that's like
step one if we're to have any hope in
this culture
of solving any of these problems and
reclaiming it at all then it's going to
require us all to have some courage
and speak up and not be silent
understanding
that there are going to be consequences
and we will suffer those consequences
and the consequences might be severe for
us we might lose
money we might lose you know
we might we might lose standing in our
community we might we might
have our friends and family turn against
us i mean all that might happen it
probably will happen for a lot of us but
we have to be willing to endure that or
there's no hope
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated